One of the largest floods in human history
might have started a civilization.
It begins with an earthquake
4,000 years ago in what is now China.
When the quake strikes,
it sets off a landslide,
stopping up a Yellow River gorge
with a wide pile of rocky debris.
At the same time,
the earthquake causes
the collapse of a downstream village --
killing some 20 villagers,
but leaving this bowl of noodles unscathed.
Back at the Yellow River gorge,
water begins to pile up
behind the landslide dam.
An enormous lake forms over
the course of a few months.
When water starts flowing over the top of
the makeshift dam
it quickly gives way,
sending a flood racing
hundreds of kilometers downstream—
scouring the gorge and riverbed,
and filling the earthquake fissures
around the Lajia site with sediment.
The sediment deposits
reveal that the earthquake
and flood happened the same year.
Scientists were the able to radiocarbon date
the remains of the villagers
to around 1900 BCE.
This is where the founding of a
civilization part comes in.
The first Chinese dynasty--the Xia dynasty--
was once known as
the “legendary dynasty.”
The only evidence that it existed
came from historic texts written
500 years after the fact.
What we know from those writings
is that the Xia dynasty started
with a giant flood.
If the Xia did exist -- and
that’s always been a big “if” --
the problem is dating it.
According to the history books,
China’s first dynasty was
started around 2070 BCE
and was led by Emperor Yu,
who earned the heavenly
mandate to rule
after spending decades
controlling flood waters.
The problem is,
there’s been no archeological
evidence to support that story.
Until now.
The legendary flood waters
controlled by Yu
could have been from this
very real outburst flood
on the Yellow River.
What’s more, this new date for the flood
lines up neatly with the
transition from Neolithic
to the Bronze age
culture in ancient China.
If the researchers are correct,
that means the trigger for
this massive cultural transformation--
and the start of the Xia dynasty--
was an extreme natural event.